You people with a mission dat involved in the
I am Europe project which I must get
Europe citizens boring gagged in politics so being talked about hang
de binge Europe de necessary
tools de citizen certain tor which there
actually a lawyers people you launch
domain per legislation is  You must set
resolutions, you need something else, you
organize town hall meetings across
Europe, different European cities, you discuss your
future of Europe, you discuss certain
topics, you set a priority, you turn
out, your happy, and
elections 62% and 1979  JUST 43% LAST
TIME
D NEWLY YOU MEMBER LET RUN 21% NEXT
AIR WELTERFUL WAY HELP THINK YOU SUCK D
NEXT PRESIDENT OF D EUROPE COMMISSION
AND IT IS N FACT YOU REPORT CALLING ON
DET D US DOING COVERAGE PEOPLE YOU TAKE N
INTEREST
PLAYING D A  You Thousand IT and IT
Current Policies Shaikh Bhai Other Factors Look D
Biggest You In This Is Not You Do You Know
Problem In D Elections In You Also
Turn On D Great Deal In
Terms The Economics You Tell
Me Credit Procedure About So Its
Shows D I  Mean d state of things in
Europe
n political party candidate per long tu hoon were
candidate of d condition
president